Das ihr Bescheid sagt, Chico muss weg, Chet muss auch weg.
Claim Drop, Alter, das ist so krasser, Chibate, wahrscheinlich gibt es noch nicht mal Drops.
So, dass die fangen garantiert, also wir kennen, wir kennen sie ja schon. Die fangen mit FIFA an,
das heißt wir Residenz-Leapen jetzt erstmal eine Viertelstunde. Danach kommt irgendwie Need for
Speed oder irgendwie anderes Residenz-Leaper-Zeug. Ok, Pock, es geht los, Fullscreen, World Premiere,
ah nee, das war Xbox. Mal gucken, ob Lautstärke passt, Leute. Oh, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Anzeige ist
raus, Leute. Toss, erstmal Musik ausmachen, Alter. Warum ist da eine Kuh und? Ok. Was, Pre-Show?
Ich will keine Pre-Show. Sims 4 Cottage Living, yeah, Mann, endlich. Leute, seid ihr auch so gehypt?
Endlich. Ich bin mir bei denen immer nicht sicher, ob die trollen oder ob sie das ernst meinen.
Ein bisschen lauter machen, aber das interessiert mich jetzt nicht, was die erzählen. Leute, die
trollen, die trollen nicht, die trollen nicht. Was meinen die ernst? Ich mach dann richtig laut,
wenn der Countdown weg ist. Das, das ist jetzt Residenz-Residenz-Leaper.
Was bin ich sehend?
Wie viel kostet ein Mal Rollen?
10 Euro.
aber ich muss mal kurz meine im autobus anpassen
was sehen wir da gerade
irgendwie passt die musik überhaupt nicht dazu
das hört sich so nach epischer keine ahnung her der ringeschlacht an und in wirklichkeit läuft
an den würfeln mit mit weinen
was wir tun
mit
Okay, alles klar.
Mehr Microtransaction. Wie ist denn das?
Leute, meine Frage an euch.
Jetzt muss mal kurz hier, kurz EA, muss mal kurz ruhig sein.
Spielt jemand von euch Apex?
Wie schlimm ist dort das der Microtransaction und Payment Faktor?
Geht?
Oh nein, FIFA, geh mal weg.
Übrigens, übrigens.
FIFA kommt ja immer irgendwie in ein halbes Jahr raus, bevor das Jahr anfängt, was es im Namen hat.
Echt, okay. Niko Rock, Dankeschön.
Machine Learning?
Wozu braucht man genau bei FIFA Machine Learning?
Ich glaube, das macht sich einfach nur cool.
Man sagt jetzt zu allem Machine Learning und Blockchain.
Das soll richtig nice sein.
Ich glaube, das ist genau warum wir in Indie-Studios sind.
Denn diese Authentizität ist wertvoll, um zu kämpfen.
Es ist wertvoll, um zu kämpfen.
Man muss Leute für ein bisschen Faith fragen, um mit ihrer Idee zu stehen.
Okay, wir sind nicht sicher, was es werden wird.
Und dann werden sie sagen, weißt du was, geh für's.
Sie geben dir den Raum und Platz, um zu spielen.
Jetzt wusste er aber hart überlegen, was er sagt, oder?
So nach dem Motto, wir interviewen sie jetzt, sagen sie mal was Gutes.
Es ist so beautiful, unique und...
Ah, Battlefield.
Der Typ, der sieht voll aus, oder was ist das für ein?
Der sieht ein bisschen aus, finde ich auch.
Der sieht aus wie einer aus Vikings.
Das habe ich mir schon mal am ersten Event gedacht.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, der könnte ein zweites aus Vikings sein.
Ah, warte mal, ich stelle mal kurz die Kategorie V um.
Ich habe ja noch Just Chatting.
Geht ja noch gar nicht los.
Ich nenne mal um Special Events.
Jawoll.
Oh ja, Sportspiele, endlich.
Oh, habt ihr das gesehen hier, AI im Ball.
Ballphysik, Ball-KI.
Jetzt hier Call of Duty hat es vorgemacht mit der Fisch-KI.
FIFA hat jetzt die Ball-KI.
Das ist bestimmt Toss-Musik.
Ich glaube, das ist die Toss-Musik.
Ich lösche schon mal das Wort, Leute.
Wenn ihr das Wort immer schief haben wollt, Mods, schneidet mit.
Ich lösche das Wort mal.
Ich weiß nie, was hier Toss-mäßig passiert.
Oh, ist weg.
Battlefield, ja, Battlefield kommt in frühestens 6 Minuten 45.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn es nach mir geht, würden die Battlefields zeigen.
Oder das wäre Ruhe.
Weil der Rest von IEM-Ich wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht.
Okay, Apex können sie noch zeigen.
Ihr wisst, ich bin überhaupt kein Battle Royale-Spieler.
Aber rein vom Zugucken her und Movement und sowas,
gefällt mir Apex einfach am besten.
Ich spiele es nicht, aber wenn ich die Auswahl habe,
bei was ich zugucke, dann ist es Apex.
Meine Güte, dieses Glauben.
Egal Leute, wir müssen durch, keine Chance jetzt.
Wir müssen da jetzt durch.
FIFA wird keine News in der Main Show geben.
Denn wir geben es dir jetzt.
Unglaublich, ja.
Fans von FIFA Ultimate Team wissen,
dass dieses Jahr einige Fan-Favorite-Footballer
in der Form von FIFA Ultimate Team Heroes zurückkommen.
Was für ein Ding.
Und 22.
Und 22. Okay, das ist eine unglückliche Abkürzung irgendwie.
Okay, das ist eine unglückliche Abkürzung irgendwie.
Aber gut.
Was für eine scheiß Abkürzung.
Alles so Titanfall 2 gespielt, ja.
Aber ich habe sogar Titanfall 1 gespielt.
Oh, early.
Und wie kriegt man es early?
Weil man Geld bezahlt führt.
Wer hat das gedacht?
Die tun fast so.
Also schenken sie einem was.
Man muss den Kram kaufen, dass man es bekommt.
Ich bin nur wegen der Main Show hier.
Ich will euch überhaupt nichts sehen.
Der Chat trifft genau das, was ich gerade denke.
A woman will rise, bearing the mark of the moth.
I want to lose, tell my story.
MonkaS.
Weird Champ.
Extremer Weird Champ.
Wie von sunu
Okay, hoffentlich fängt gleich an drei minuten
Huge ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen battlefield wird richtig nice eine sache die ich mir schon jahrelang wünsche
Für nicht nur für mehr viel für viele games ich hoffe dass es was taugt am endeffekt also man muss ja sagen
Ich ich habe ja das neue battlefield von dem was man gesehen hat bisher immer gelobt ich muss jetzt aber eine sache klarstellen
Ja, ich finde das cool was man sieht und das cool was man bisher
Also was man so gezeigt bekommen hat
Das das game am endeffekt was taugt das will ich damit gar nicht sagen
Das kann so geil aussehen und wenn es am ende rauskommt spielt sich kacke das weiß man ja nicht
Weiß man ja nicht ja das war apex
Wenn krenn bazaar uns und sehen
krossing meinste kommt als du nie meistern springe ich in die luft
Salomon 95
Ich darf noch nicht sagen aber was ich sagen kann glaube ich ist du legst nicht so weit daneben
Aber was genau gibt es nicht
Ich bin hier um das Traum eine Realität zu machen. Lasst uns direkt in die Aktion mit dem F1 2021 Trailer
Formel eins okay wir haben noch nicht gibt leute wir haben noch nicht genug resident sleeper jetzt kommt noch Formel eins
Dieses Kind ist ein neuer Nr. 1 Fahrer
Jawoll
Wir machen jetzt a ja ja racinger
Musik moment tostmusik tostmusik
Tostmusik
Tostmusik moment
Tostmusik bestimmt tostmusik ist alles tostmusik heutzutage weißt du nie
Ich bräuchte irgendwas zum über zum überspielen so hier
Bäm das das passt doch mario kart musik ist glaube ich gar kein mario kart
Tostmusik
Exzellent gleich viel besser
Okay 35 sekunde gleich geht es los als nächstes mache ich tocs tocs super tocs kater als overlay
Ja okay auf geht's so leute zack zack
Ich bin andy mcnamara. Ich denke du bist noch andy mcnamara und ich bin alex sacrament. Danke, dass du so viel
gesungen hast und es war ein stück lauter
Erschreckt mich nicht so was schreit er da einfach jetzt rum
Wer?
Er hat bestimmt super schwere controller die er hält für die oberarme
Kannst du den stream lauter machen der ist doch übelst laut aber wobei du hast recht
Es hat jetzt erst angefangen
Residenz sleeper sport games please was geht mit ihm eigentlich grad ab
Wie sie immer so auf fake hype machen alter
Oh nee jetzt kommen sport games
Oh nein sport spiele und rennspiele
Ist das tocs musik
Das ist bestimmt tocs ist das tocs musik leute ist es safe
Dann wenn ihr sagt dass es safe ist ich mache mal ein bisschen leiser ich finde die musik echt ätzend
Battlefield zeigen die vor apex damit die apex leute warten das kann durchaus sein
Übrigens dass die musik so übersteuert ist das liegt nicht an mir das gehört dazu
Ich habe leiser gemacht weil es mir zu laut ist beziehungsweise zu anstrengend laut
Wer hätte das gedacht sie ist so excited
Es ist noch nie vorgekommen dass jemand excited war auf solchen shows
Das ist das erste mal world premiere excitement
Ich muss ehrlich sagen ich weiß nicht wer das ist aber ich interessiert mich auch
Null für rennsport
Ich hoffe ihr seid auch so excited
Ich glaube wir brauchen trink monka stea als emote oder
Bitchles family
Es ist der Zeit für eine andere Art von Legende.
Zwei Jahre ago kamen Apex-Legende aus nowhere.
Und jetzt gibt es 100 Millionen Spieler und 17 Legenden später.
Es wird einfach immer größer.
Apex macht denen, glaube ich, gerade das weiste Geld.
Habe ich irgendwo gelesen.
Das hat Millionen gemacht schon.
Also Apex ist wirklich krass.
Für EA.
Oder FIFA.
Ich sage mal, für Games, wo ich mich interessiere,
FIFA kein Schimmer. Nein, mehr als FIFA bestimmt nicht.
Er hat krass viel Geld gemacht.
Das neue Helden-Teaser?
Moment, wie heißen die in Apex?
Operators, Specialists, Helden?
Pilots?
Ach, Legends.
Wie heißt das einfach?
High Effect-Type.
Ich meine, die haben mit Apex
über eine Milliarde schon verdient.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Oder Billion.
Wie die Amis sagen.
Ist das Blade?
Machen die eigentlich auch Cross-Offers wie Fortnite?
Ja.
Schreckt.
Ja, Alter. Ist gut. Ist gut.
Huge-Ektik.
Chat?
Ach so, Chat.
Da haben sie sich alle gefreut, dass sie sich jetzt
ins Teams-Meeting setzen dürfen und einmal jubeln.
Leute, es kommt alles wieder. Jetzt gibt's da auch Heartbeat-Sensors.
Einschätzung von den Apex-Spielern, Chat?
Ist das OP oder nicht?
Alles OP, okay.
Es gibt eine Sache, die nicht OP ist.
Ja, ich habe auch gesagt, dass Bloodhound ein Tracker ist.
Aber wie Bloodhound, ist Seer eine sehr präzise Information.
Er ist ein bisschen mehr einer Stealth-Orienten-Legende.
Und du wirst, glaube ich, ein paar Interaktionen sehen,
wegen der Sphäre, die ich erwähnt habe, sein Ultimate.
Wenn du schnell durch diesen Raum gehst,
werden deine Füße entdeckt.
Aber wenn du langsam schlägst, kannst du die Entdeckung entdecken.
Ich denke, du wirst ein paar interessante Gameplay-Experienzen sehen
und neue Wege zu spielen, die sich ein bisschen zerstören.
Ja, es klingt so, dass, wenn die Ringe festgeteilt wird,
wirst du eine Menge neuen Wege für dieses Spiel haben.
Aber in dieser Saison, zum Beispiel,
fühlt sich Apex wirklich über Battle Royale ausgerichtet,
mit der Erinnerung der Arenas.
Was ist die Reaktion für euch gewesen?
Die Fan-Reaktion war wirklich toll.
Wir sehen, dass viele Spieler die Arenas genießen.
Das ist toll.
Wir sind echt gespannt,
dass es endlich eine Art ist, Apex-Legende über Battle Royale zu spielen.
Ja, die Leute lieben es.
Wir haben also neue Maps in der Arbeit.
Und einige andere Dinge kommen,
die ich noch nicht sagen wollen.
Aber wir haben viele Pläne für Arenas.
Alles klar, fair, fair.
Ich weiß, dass ihr auch Ranking-Arenas eröffnet habt.
Kannst du uns ein paar Informationen dazu geben?
Wir haben jetzt eine Saison von Arenas unter unseren Bälten.
Wir wollten, dass wir sehen,
wie die Spieler sich in die Mode vertreten.
Wir sind echt gespannt,
dass es im September auf der Apex-Level
ein Jahr oder zwei auf der Apex-Level wird.
Wir werden Overwatch und Xbox-Spieler
mit den PC-Spielern spielen.
Wir werden sehen, wer der Beste ist.
Und ein ganz neues Liga-Format.
Wir haben noch mehr Informationen
an playapex.com slash ALGS.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Und, Chad, bevor du los,
muss ich dich fragen.
Wann können wir mehr von Seer sehen?
Wir haben einen tollen Gameplay-Trailer
am Montag.
Und es wird im August 3.
Und jetzt kann ich dir einen Finisher zeigen.
Natürlich, bitte.
Ja, das ist alles, was ich sehen muss.
Es ist einfach so toll.
Aber, Chad, danke, dass du hier bist.
Danke, Austin.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Und wieder,
eine große Schöne an das ganze Respawn-Team.
Jetzt für die Apex-Fans,
die uns heute auf Twitch schauen.
Respawn hat einen exklusiven
Jump-Master-Gun-Charme.
Also macht sicher, dass du deinen Twitch-
und EA-Account linkst.
Und bleib auf der Apex-Level schauen,
um den Fall zu erzielen.
Aber das ist nicht das Einzige,
das wir heute geben.
Wir geben dir einen Link,
in dem du den Code
für deine Chance erzielen kannst,
zum Beispiel
für EA-Originals,
wie Knockout City und It Takes Two.
Speaking of Originals,
Let's head across the ocean
for some stop-motion
and check out a soon-to-be-released
EA-Original-Boss
in the West.
Hello?
Distoled, bewildered
by the voice coming from somewhere unknown.
Somewhere random.
Ah, okay.
Alright, anyway, it's coming soon
and it looks really cool.
Justin stopped himself.
Why, he'd forgotten to mention
the Tribeca Film Festival selection.
Es ist der Sprecher.
It was a selection at the Tribeca Film Festival.
He tried the line again.
More enthusiastically.
Look, man, I'm trying to run a whole show.
Really selling it.
Could you just let me intro the segment?
Ja, ey.
Mehr gestellte Show, please.
It was an official Tribeca Film Festival selection
this summer and it's coming soon.
Joining us from Gothenburg, Sweden
to tell us more
is Zoink Creative Director
Olaf Redmond.
Hello, Austin.
How's it going, Olaf?
Thank you so much for joining us
and congratulations on Tribeca.
It's so cool to see video games
right next to movies
like this.
Thank you, Austin.
I'm so proud of the Zoink team
and what we've accomplished
and I'm so happy about the selection
because Lost in Random is really inspired
by all these movies that I grew up with
and stop-motion animation
and dark fairy tales.
At Zoink, we're always trying to push narrative
in video games, so I'm so happy.
Well, I can't wait to see more,
Olaf, of my life.
What do you have for us today?
Den mag ich. Er ist so pleased.
Er ist nicht excited.
Okay, na doch.
Er übertreibt es
wenigstens nicht so.
Das haben wir doch gerade schon mal gesehen.
Was meint ihr eigentlich, wie gut Würfel
rollen mit Beinen?
Leute, Leute,
die beste Überleitung wäre,
wenn sie jetzt sagen würden,
von Dicey weiter zu Schweden
zu Dice oder sowas.
Das wäre Big Brain Überleitung.
Massive Pfeil Pferd.
Pfeil Pferd.
Das ist so eine Mischung aus
Adventure und Deck-Bilder
oder sowas.
Und jetzt kostet es erstmal 5 Euro
im Shop.
Sonst geht es
gerne nicht weiter.
Wenn sie noch einmal Dicey sagen.
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen,
jetzt muss ich mir irgendwas ausdenken,
was ich sage.
Zum Glück habe ich es erledigt.
Ich finde, Karten klingen schon mal
hart nach Dicey-Battle.
Ja.
Ich habe hier
ein paar Karten.
Gute Böses!
Böses!
Dom Dice!
registered
knight
White
die sich in diesen dringenden Zeitbomben verändern.
Du musst einfach vorsichtig sein, damit er nicht schlägt.
Das ist doch egal.
Und wo ist dieser Hammer?
Fuck, du hast ihn verpasst.
Der gibt sogar eine super Stärke, um ihn zu schwingen.
Offensive Manöver, ich mag es.
Aber es geht nicht nur um Offensive.
Wir haben auch für einen Beispiel Uma's Blessing,
die von Uma, dieser alten, geheimen Witch, kommt.
Und sie gibt einen Schild, um Even zu schützen.
Und das ist nur ein Geschmack.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Stärken, die du hast.
Einige schützen Gegner, einige schützen Even oder kreieren Treppen.
Einige Arenas arbeiten auch als gigantische Board-Games,
verursacht von Rolling Dicey.
Du musst also verschiedene Taktiken ausprobieren,
um die Queen's Giant Mad Tabletop-themed Arenas zu gewinnen.
Okay, Olaf.
Meine nächste Frage. Du weißt, was kommt.
Wann können wir dieses Spiel spielen?
Ja, meine Lieblingsfrage.
Lost in Random eröffnet am 10. September
auf PC, Konsolen und Nintendo Switch.
Und du kannst nach der Show beginnen.
Und wenn du einen eigenen Dicey-Kompetent willst,
wird er zur EA-Play-Members available
als Gun Charm in einem meiner aktuellen Favoriten, Apex.
Also, schau dir das an.
Na ja, ihr habt es zuerst gehört.
Und Olaf, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute dabei seid.
Es war mein absoluter Freude, Austin, und willkommen zu Random.
Danke.
Da ist sie, Anhänger.
Lost in Random kommt bald,
aber es gibt einen anderen EA-Original, der schon hier ist.
Wo?
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt Battlefield.
Okay.
Thanks, Austin. Wir sind so dankbar für unsere Community
für die massive Antwort auf Knockout City.
Mit Millionen neuer Brawlers,
hunderts von Tausenden Crews
und fast ein Billion K.O.s landeten.
Deine Antwort war wirklich ein Knockout.
Als ein indie Team, dedikiert...
Okay, ich hab noch nie was davon gehört.
...habe alle von euch diese einzigartige Sache
gemacht. Das ist ein tolles Gefühl.
Und ich will nur sagen, danke.
Am Launchen haben wir euch neue Features und Updates
versprochen, die das Spiel frisch und aufregend halten.
Heute bin ich hier, um das Versprechen zu erledigen.
Auf der Seite des ganzen Velen Studios Team
ist es mein absoluter Freude, Knockout City Season 2
zu zeigen.
Okay.
Leute, ich muss jetzt da mal was nachgucken.
Leute, Leute.
Ich muss mal schnell nebenbei was gucken.
Oh.
Das ist ja massiv beliebt.
Riesenhype.
Also...
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht so nicht das allerbeliebteste Game.
Ich mein, hey.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Steam ist nicht das Einzige.
Steam ist nicht das Einzige.
Und 613 Player.
Peak ist mehr, als die meisten Spiele auf Steam haben.
Fair misshalber, ja.
Boss, Boss.
Das Acting von dem Typ ist einfach so real.
Ich kauf ihm jede Emotion ab.
Oh.
Endlich.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was ihr sagt.
Es wird wild.
Was, lauter?
Das ist laut genug.
Oder lauter, Leute.
Ich mach eins lauter noch.
Okay.
Jetzt aber, jetzt reicht's.
Oh nein.
Ich bin dafür auch gehypt, als ich das gesehen hab.
Aber diese Reactions jetzt.
Oh.
Na gut, okay, warum nicht.
Ich komm, ja.
Ich bin auch drin, habt ihr mich nicht gesehen.
Der Wikinger ist back.
Jetzt.
Dice LA, ist das Danger Close gewesen?
Werft die vielleicht noch durcheinander.
Es ist kein Battlefield-Ultimate-Team.
Es ist kein Battle Royale.
Habt ihr Caspian Border gesehen?
Habt ihr Valparaiso gesehen?
Habt ihr die Battlefield Bad Company 2-Granate gesehen?
Deswegen.
By the way, soll ich euch mal was sagen, dieses ganze Battlefield-Trailer-Zeug würde viel geiler ankommen mit dem Battlefield-Team unten drunter.
Ich fände sogar den Namen mal ganz gut.
Es ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht das, was ihr denkt.
Wartet mal ab, wartet mal ab, wartet mal ab, Leute.
Wie wollen sie das balancen, wartet mal ab, wartet mal ab.
Also auf gut Deutsch, das ist ein Level-Editor.
Besser als Halo Forge, besser als Halo Forge, wartet mal ab, bis ich es zeige, ich darf noch nichts erzählen.
Ich wette mit dir, ich wette mit dir, er hat keines dieser Maps je selbst gespielt.
Ja, das wollte ich euch zeigen, das ist nicht wie der Halo-Level-Editor, du kannst wirklich Logik programmieren drin.
Okay, so kann ich World War 2 gegen 2042? Ja, du kannst. Okay, was ist mit dem Spiel-Mode? Kann ich einen Infektions-Mode machen, in dem ich gegen viele super-feste Soldaten mit Knifen bin? Absolut.
Okay, was ist mit Schadensknifen? Aber nicht nur regular Schadensknifen, wie ein Waffe-Spiel mit ganzen Schadensknifen aus der ganzen Geschichte.
Das ist eine sehr spezifische Idee, Austin, aber ja, eigentlich kannst du es.
Bring it home, kann ich als Schadensknifen-Penguin spielen? Schadensknifen-Penguin? Nein, ich meine, es gibt einige Limiten.
Es ist kein Level-Editor, du kannst die Maps nicht selbst editieren, und nein, du kannst als Schadensknifen-Penguin spielen.
Das ist okay, das ist okay, das muss ich fragen, aber es klingt, als ob es viele Möglichkeiten gibt, mit dem Spiel zu spielen.
Oh ja, die Optionen sind ziemlich tief, und wir sind engagiert, mit der Community zu arbeiten, um diese Art von Tools und Content zu bauen, sobald das Spiel entwickelt.
Wir wollen, dass diese Erfahrung geht, wo du es nehmen möchtest. Wir sehen den Sandbox als große Teil der Zukunft von Battlefield 2042.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das ist ein Level-Editor. Es ist nur ein Logik-Editor anscheinend.
Ich dachte aber, es ist ein Level-Editor.
Ich habe auch nicht aufgepasst, als sie uns das vorgestellt haben, muss ich sagen.
Oder nur halb aufgepasst, und ich habe diesen Logik-Editor gesehen, habe direkt gedacht, es muss ein Level-Editor sein.
Das ist Qualität gegen Quantität von Gavitron.
Ein kleiner Squad von 2042 nimmt 32 Spieler von 1942 an.
Die Zukunft hat die Hardware, aber die Passen haben die Nummern.
Zerstören diese Einkommen.
Das wird man wahrscheinlich mit Bots spielen können, gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Ein echter Loll, Alter.
Und wir bekommen unsere Hände auf Portal at Launch, oder?
Ja, Portal wird am 1. März bei Launch eröffnet,
mit einer Bühne von Pre-Made-Modes, die du sofort probieren kannst.
Okay, das ist fantastisch. Christian, bevor du losgehst,
lassen wir uns darauf achten, dass ich alles in Ordnung habe.
Aufgrund von allen Content und Maps, die bereits erwähnt worden sind, bekommen wir auch Content aus Battlefield 1942, Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3,
mit 6 der besten Maps aller Zeiten, und alles, was erfolgreich ist, geht ich davon aus, die Release noch mehr Maps.
Und dann haben wir noch ein Hazard-Zone dieses Jahr?
Ja, das ist genau das, was ich dir sage, Austin.
Wenn du immer ein Fan bist, oder wenn du nie Battlefield gespielt hast,
bin es aber schade, dass es kein Level-Editor ist.
Da habe ich euch Mist erzählt vorhin.
Also, als sie es gezeigt haben.
Ich dachte eigentlich selbst, es ist ein Level-Editor.
Ich hoffe, dass ihr das Show genossen habt, so wie ich es genossen habe, euer Host zu sein.
Mein Name ist Austin Creed, und unser letztes Reveal ist irgendwo da drüben.
Bilder nicht rein.
Vom Sound und der Optik?
Dead Space?
Es hört sich stark nach Dead Space an.
Ah, FIFA, okay, sorry.
Dead Space muss Dead Space sein.
Dead Space Mobile.
Das ist das Raumschiff aus dem ersten Teil?
Ist das ein Remake?
Oder was ist das jetzt?
Also, wenn es ein Remake ist, dann sage ich euch mal ganz ehrlich,
es ist ein Remake, das die Welt nicht braucht.
Dead Space 1 sieht immer noch top aus.
Das ist jetzt fertig, ja.
Also, wenn das wirklich ein Remake ist, dann braucht es die Welt wirklich nicht.
Macht das noch was?
Der Code war It's Back, ja.
Sollen wir mal kurz gucken, ob ich das Asset Pack jetzt öffnen kann,
dass wir uns das Battlefield-Ding nochmal angucken können?
Asset Pack hier.
Schaffen wir nicht aufmachen, erst in vier Minuten, Leute.
Erst in vier Minuten darf ich es öffnen.
MonkaS.
So, genau, sonst kommt die Feuerwehr.
Ich glaube, das war es, Leute.
Ich glaube, da kommt nichts mehr jetzt.
Mal kurz ein bisschen leise und wieder ein bisschen gedudel an.
Ja, ich muss sagen, mich hat nichts geschockt außer Battlefield.
Und selbst das wusste ich schon und ich habe mich auch noch vertan.
Leute, ich dachte, der Desktop, der ist richtig gut so.
Ich habe gedacht, es ist ein Level Editor.
Aber ich muss zu meiner Verteidigung sagen, ich habe genau zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo die Ankündigung war und wo die uns das gezeigt haben,
versucht, die New World Beta zu installieren und Charakter zu erstellen,
damit ich reinkomme.
Ich habe nur auf dem zweiten Bildschirm ein bisschen zugeguckt.
Und das, was ich gesehen habe, war dieser Logic Editor.
Und ich habe instant gedacht, das muss ein Level Editor sein.
Weißt du, wann der Public Beta ist?
Gucken wir mal in das Asset Pack, ob da irgendwas drinsteht.
Sie haben was gesagt, ja.
Public weiß ich nicht.
Wir müssen noch zwei Minuten warten, Leute.
Wo kann man den Code eingeben? Keine Ahnung.
Habt ihr jetzt eigentlich noch was? Nee.
Jetzt fertig.
Okay, ich glaube, für die Leute, die Apex spielen, war was Gutes dabei.
Für die Battlefield-Leute war auch was dabei.
Dieses Adventure-Game, okay, muss man mal gucken.
Dieses komische, wir werfen uns mit dem Ball ab-Game, hat mich überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Ja gut, und Rennspiele und FIFA jucken mich ja prinzipiell nicht.
Chat aktivieren, jawoll, wir machen den Chat wieder rein.
Und Chico, Chico muss auch wieder rein, perfekt.
Leute, noch 50 Sekunden, dann darf ich es euch zeigen. Wir können es ja schon mal entpacken.
Alter, wie groß ist denn das?
Wie groß ist das denn? Was ist denn da alles drin?
1.16 GB
Wie sehr muss da es getriggert sein, dass das Freund geleakt wurde? Was wurde denn geleakt?
Dass es Battlefield Portal heißen wird oder was?
Wurde das geleakt? Ach so, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Einer hat auf die NDA geschissen, ja, gibt immer so was. So, jetzt darf ich es euch zeigen.
Community-Gameplay-Videos, was gibt es da? Zeig her, Community-Gameplay-Videos, was haben wir da drin zu sehen?
Ich habe mir das noch nicht angeguckt, Leute.
Okay, das haben wir schon gesehen, das ist das gleiche, was wir gerade schon gesehen haben.
Okay, nichts Neues. Wahrscheinlich sind im ganzen Assetpack nichts Neues.
Aber gut, das ist ja auch ein Assetpack, das heißt ja nicht, dass was...
Okay, da steht nur noch mal die NDAs und sowas drin.
Infographic, also was haben wir hier?
Also, was ist in Portal dabei?
Es gibt Content aus 1942 bei der Competition Battlefield 3.
Ehrlich gesagt, Leute, ich habe echt gedacht, das ist, also ich habe, ich habe an einem Stream, wo ich, wie gesagt, ich habe es nur auf dem zweiten Bildschirm geguckt.
Ich habe das da gesehen und gesagt, cool, ein Map-Editor mit so einem, so einem...
Wie heißt es bei Unreal? So eine Art Blue Box-Geschichte oder nee, Blue Print-Geschichte.
So Logic Blocks, das ist für die Noobs, die nicht programmieren können und lieber Plugger zusammenstöpseln.
Habe ich gedacht, ey, das muss ein Level-Editor sein, ist das aber gar nicht.
Da habe ich mich vertan.
Also es gibt keine, keine wirklichen Mods in Form von neuen, also neuen Maps oder, oder stark veränderten Maps.
Es gibt halt einen, einen Spielmodus-Editor.
Das ist aber auch schon mal cool im Vergleich zu dem, dass du in der Vergangenheit nichts machen kannst.
Wobei ich mich halt echt frage...
Also, wie soll ich sagen? Das täuscht ja nicht darüber hinweg.
Also, sollen wir mal von ausgehen?
Also, wenn wir jetzt mal von ausgehen würden, die hätten halt kein Content für Battlefield 2042, dann kann man damit auch nicht drüber hinweg täuschen.
Zusätzlich ist es natürlich geil.
Ach ja, übrigens, was ich euch auch erzählen darf, das muss man nicht in-Game machen.
Es gibt so eine Art Web-IDE dafür.
Ich nenne es mal IDE. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es aussehen wird.
Es gibt so eine Art Web-Editor dafür. Man muss es nicht in-Game machen.
Also sprich, man kann es wenigstens ordentlich, ordentlich bedienen.
Hoffe ich mal.
Ich nenne es mal IDE. Wie soll ich... Ja, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ein Web-Editor. Logo. Screenshots.
Ok, das Asset Pack kann man sich im Prinzip auch sparen.
Es ist halt ein grafisch schönes Waldparaiso.
Ein schickes Caspian Border.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal als alte Hacker-Mans mal an, was wir hier sehen.
Also als erstes brauche ich einen Wim-Plugin. Genau, ohne Wim-Plugin tut sich hier schon mal gar nichts.
Ganz ehrlich, mir ist einfach Source-Code lieber. Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend gerade?
Es ist im Prinzip leer. Man sieht hier eigentlich gar nichts, oder?
Es ist einfach nur Blöcke hingemacht, ohne dass man Inhalt sieht.
Es ist ja auch null miteinander verknüpft.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und man kann wirklich eine ordentliche Programmiersprache verwenden als das.
Mit-Logo. Ok, jetzt gibt es das Ganze mal mit-Logo.
Also mir persönlich wäre eine ordentliche Programmiersprache lieber als so.
Aber gut.
Genau, Experten-Modus mit Quellcode wäre schon cool.
Ansonsten habe ich halt die Frage, ich weiß halt nicht, wer sich die Mühe macht.
Da bin ich jetzt so ein bisschen zwiegespalten, weil du hast auf der einen Seite die Hacker-Mann-Leute,
die sowas interessieren, die können aber in der Regel auch programmieren.
Es ist doch egal, ob Frostbite C++ ist. Wenn die sowas da als Frontend basteln können,
da können sie das auch für Python oder irgendwelche x-beliebige andere Sprache machen.
Da sind ja eh schon die Hacker-Mann-Leute, die das interessiert.
Und die können in der Regel auch, und selbst wenn es C++ wäre, wenn das Zeug ordentlich spendant ist,
ist alles in Ordnung, die können eh programmieren.
Den anderen interessiert es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also ich bin echt skeptisch, inwieweit das mehr Leute dazu bringt, was zu machen.
Kann man ändern, wie viel XP man kommt als in einen Cheatserver?
Das wird nichts bringen, weil das unterschiedliche Spiel, also getrennte Module im Spiel sind.
Das ist Battlefield 2042 All-Out Warfare, das ist der Hauptspielmodus.
Dann hast du Battlefield Portal und du hast Hazard Zone.
Das sind drei verschiedene Module in dem Game.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das eine mit dem anderen nicht so wirklich interagieren kann.
Also wenn du hier XP hoch machst, falls das überhaupt geht,
dann wird das wahrscheinlich nicht aufs normale Battlefield auswirken.
Was ist das, Cross-Progression? Das wäre aber, dann kannst du die XP nicht ändern.
Das wäre sonst alles andere, wäre äußerst merkwürdig.
Gehe nochmal auf die Übersicht, zeige ich mal her.
Welche?
Äh, das da?
Hier, Earn XP and Rank no matter where you play.
Das finde ich merkwürdig.
Ja, dann gibt es gleich irgendwelche easy Unlock-Maps.
Das ist ja geil, überleg mal, da kannst du ja voll bescheißen.
Also was heißt bescheißen? Bescheißen in einem anderen Stil.
Überlegt euch mal, es gibt einen Erfolg, 50 Headshots mit der Sniper.
Dann machst du einfach eine Map, wo die Leute spawnen Headshot only.
Sodass die Leute sich nicht bewegen oder so, nicht bewegen können.
Und du machst einfach die ganze Zeit Headshot, Headshot, Headshot.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Oh, lagged das Stream?
Oh.
Vodafone.
Frame drops as fuck.
Alter.
Vodafone.
Hör mal auf.
Okay, scheint wieder zu gehen.
Nee, leg nicht an dir, leg dein Vodafone.
Ist schon vorbei, ja.
Okay, das mit Cross-Progression habe ich nicht gesehen, aber das verwundert mich enorm, dass das Cross-Progression ist.
Ohne Miss, das wundert mich echt enorm.
Aber eigentlich, überlegt euch mal, eigentlich ist es noch nicht mal gut, dass das Cross-Progression ist.
Weil Cross-Progression limitiert das, was sie an Features dort einbauen können.
Überlegt euch mal, sie wollten es wirklich zu einem Map-Editor ausbauen.
Und noch mehr vielleicht, dass man sogar eigene Sachen komplett neu createn kann.
Das ist broken für Cross-Progression.
Wo steht das mit Cross-Progression? Hier unten.
Shared Progression.
Meinen die damit nicht die Konsolen?
Ja, also wenn das, normalerweise würde ich sagen, die meinen die Konsolen.
Aber wenn das explizit auf dem Platz steht, wo es um Battlefield Portal geht, dann wird sich das auch auf Battlefield Portal beziehen.
Ich meine, es macht doch keinen Sinn, hier alles was für Battlefield Portal zu schreiben und dann da unten Shared Progression.
Aber ja, es ist übrigens auch so, du kannst, zumindest haben wir es das letzte Mal gesagt, du kannst wohl Progression shareen zwischen Konsole und PC.
Wird es einen Serverbrowser geben? Dazu haben sie sich bisher immer echt hardcore gedrückt, da direkt drauf zu antworten.
Wir haben sie gefragt, in der ersten FAQ gab es keine direkte Antwort drauf.
In der zweiten FAQ wurden sie gefragt, es gab keine direkte Antwort drauf.
Und mit der Zeit hat man auch noch nichts gesehen.
Also sprich, Skill-Based Matchmaking ist immer noch im Rennen für das Game.
Und eins sage ich euch, gibt es Skill-Based Matchmaking, gibt es mich in dem Spiel nicht?
Das werde ich mir nicht geben.
Porzepa das Cute Squad, das stimmt, aber mit dem Cute Squad macht es auch keinen Bock, wenn du nur gegen Ultra-Tryhard-Leute-Vielensohn-Sieben spielst.
Meinst du, die werden Battle-Lock-mäßig über eine Webseite gestalten? Ich vermute in-game, was ich persönlich doof finde, weil ich Battle-Lock mag.
Ich vermute, dass sie es in-game machen. Battle-Lock war eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Menüs und Optionen und Sachen kannst du richtig gut im Browser machen, das brauchst du eigentlich gar nicht neu programmieren im Spiel.
Weiß gar nicht warum man das nicht mehr macht.
Man könnte es übrigens auch ohne Probleme für Konsolen anbieten. Heute hat jeder ein Smartphone, machst eine Battle-Lock-App und kannst Join für deine Xbox.
Das wäre doch überhaupt kein Problem, das kann man doch machen.
Was ist denn ein RSP, Exori?
Spätestens seit Diablo Immortal, dass alle Phones haben.
UI in-game ist sowieso Browser, wahrscheinlich. Das stimmt schon.
Also es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas HTML-basiertes sein, gehe ich auch mal von aus. Aber trotzdem ist es über den Browser besser.
Wenn du einen kompletten Web-Service hast.
Ja klar, Battle-Lock war nicht perfekt, aber ich finde es trotzdem besser als in-game das zu machen.
Ja Leute, ich muss mal was essen. Wie gesagt, ich bin ja gerade erst on gekommen und direkt ins Stream, wo ich hier vorher eingeschaltet habe.
Ich werde jetzt nicht lange rumschwätzen, ich werde jetzt mal was essen gehen und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann, alles gut, see you.